Add the blue and
pink expressions
to create another expression.
And be sure to
combine like terms.
So let me get this
scratch pad out here.
So we need to add this
6y plus 2 in blue.
So we're going to add 6y plus 2.
And we're going to add it
to negative 2/3 minus y.
So first let's add
all the y terms.
If we have six of something,
and I'm going to subtract one
of that something,
or 6y's minus 1y--
you could view this
literally as 1y--
I'm going to be left with 5y's.
And then I have 2 minus 2/3.
And let's solve that
right over here.
So 2 minus 2/3 is
the same thing as-- 2
can be rewritten as 6/3-- 6
divided by 3 is 2-- minus 2/3,
which equals 4/3.
So 2 minus 2/3 is 4/3.
So this is equal to 5y plus 4/3.
Now let's actually input that
in to make sure we got it right.
5y plus 4/3.
And you see it
interpreted it properly.
And we got it right.